The percentage relationship you have with any given relative or
one of your family members is what we call Identity
by Descent or IBD. This is a number that's assigned
to each family member that indicates the percentage of a genome
that you would share with them based on your common
ancesters. In the same way that we have an IBS
score. We have an IBD score and they're both measured
from a range of zero to 100%. But in the case
of the IBS score, we generally go from a range
of about 70% to 100%. Right? And that's sampling SNVs
across the whole genome. But an IBD score can get
down pretty close to zero. It's almost never completely 0%. Remember,
we're all related through common ancestors at some point. So
we share some relations, but it gets to a very
low percentage at some point. And we can be all
the way up to 100% obviously if you compare it to
your own genome or if you have an identical twin.
So, in a way, what we're looking for is to see
where you're closest genetic relatives are to your furthest genetic
relatives. You may remember from lesson 5 when I introduced the
idea of the family rainbow right instead of the family
tree. And what it allows us to do is sort of
do these categories, this hierarchical
relationships using this different colors.
We can fill in each tier here, right, you 100% related
to you. Your siblings and your parents,
your 50% related to. Your half siblings, grandparents,
aunts, uncles, you're 25%. And then it
gets pretty complicated quickly, 12.5% related to your
first cousins, grand uncles, great grandparents. And
then 6.25% related to your first cousin once
removed, great grand aunt, great-great grandparents. And all
kinds of other shrubby like things coming off
this tree, or our family rainbow. And we can keep
going out. But what I like about the family rainbow
is it allows us to organize our relatives in a
way that allows us to easily visualize these tiers of genetic
relatedness to each other. Now this is all well and
good if we know our relationship with our family members already.
But, how do we calculate this percentage. Which is equal
to the IBD, the Identity by Descent score for unknown relations.
Let's actually go talk to somebody about how this IBD score is determined.